people are making fun of me for reading
a Kindle on set it's ever heard of a
book Jesse my assistant was like what
are you reading and I was like a Kindle
and she's like why would you be reading
a Kindle I'm like shouldn't wait this is
backwards like I'm the old one should I
not be why are you making fun of me for
using digital versions of books has it
reverted now because those are [__]
awesome are they not awesome except when
they power down
they did mine ran out of batteries yeah
and then Jesse goes you know it always
stays on a book
I was like cool then part of your job
now is to walk around with 30 pounds of
books in case I want one yeah and like
half of them are textbooks just in case
I want to learn something yeah just a
little math how do I find X again yeah
can't remember can you crack open that
can you find that chapter please